How do you fill out this frame, David?
>> The way I did it is I started off by
writing down what I need to expect about
an earthquake.
I knew that earthquakes
happen on a particular day.
They happen at a particular location.
They cause a certain amount of damage,
a certain number of fatalities.
They happen on a certain fault
line with certain magnitude.
They occur at a certain time.
There are different types
of earthquakes, and
they all have a certain
duration to them.
I then went to the story to try and
find the fillers for
the slots I had just written down.
So the time was today, the location
was Lower Slabovia, and so on.
Some slots didn't have fillers in
the story, but that's all right.
>> That's good, David.
Let us note a couple of
things in David's answer.
First, the slots are part of
David's background knowledge
about stereotypical earthquakes.
Second, these fillers for
the slots are coming from the story.
This is a very good example of
how both bottom-up processing and
top-down processing getting combined.
As the story came,
David noticed the word earthquake,
went into a long-term memory.
>From a semantic memory he
pulled out the frame for
the earthquake which told him what slots
to look for, and then he used bottom-up
processing to try to figure out
what values to put in there.
But note the limitation of this
combination of top-down and
bottom-up processing also.
Imagine a different story.
Here is a second story.
If you read the second story and
compare it to the first one,
you begin to see that there are lots
of subtle and nuanced meanings here.
So killed here will
happen to 25 proposals,
killing here refers to 25 people.
Sadie Hawkins here was
a science advisor,
the name of a fault.
The frame knowledge representation of
itself and by itself doesn't tell us
how to pick Sadie Hawkins as a science
advisor, and not as a fault.
Or whether the killing of 25 proposals,
how does it relate with
killing of 25 people?
We will return to this topic, and
we'll talk more about it when we come to
understanding and
common-sense reasoning in a few weeks.
>> Or if you're interested in reading
about this now, you can go ahead and
go watch those lessons.